with that kooky actress lady reading
slam poetry to vladimir putin to stop
the war in ukraine with kamala harris
reading beat poetry to bring down the
price of gas i thought this was a great
time for me to dive back into the
culture and examine the poetry of our
age that would be rap music can i stab
you i am the most hippity-hoppity here
at the daily wire the cultural maven pop
culture guru flavor mic
so we are going to be
taking a look at the latest
tom mcdonald song this video is brought
to you by expressvpn more from them
later first though let's get them sick
beats
they separate us from our neighbors and
they call it social distancing it's
actually a bigger plan it's called
social conditioning they took away our
privacy there's always someone listening
the election's planning riots for the
citizens the government has always lied
its history repeating but the problem is
the schools thumb you down so you
believe them if you try to speak the
truth inside a tweet then they delete it
whole administration satanists who claim
they praising jesus every year there's a
new name for enemies that we're facing
it's al-qaeda than isis and now american
patriots who would have thought those
who love the country the most will be
hated on by folks who call america home
okay pause it there
this is uh pretty insightful and this is
not just of america today this is true
of every regime ever you always need to
have an enemy so the the ruling regimes
will focus you on one enemy and then
another enemy and there's always a
crisis and there's always a threat from
the outside
but what what tom's pointing out here is
that the same
infrastructure the security
infrastructure that the united states
built up
first to fight in the cold war then to
oppose al qaeda then to oppose other
threats it's now been turned on american
patriots we're now told that the
greatest domestic terror threat is from
white supremacy in america how many
white supremacists are there in america
like four there's five of them in fact
we're told that the the great domestic
terror threat
is from parents who don't want their
kids to learn crt
and
crazy gender theory in schools so it's
been turned on them that is something
that's happened within just the last few
years a very very perceptive shift in in
the way we think about our grave enemies
and the gravest threats okay go
on are equally just as evil they've been
working for themselves don't give a damn
about the people black white yellow
brown humanity needs you because united
we stand divided they will defeat you
the man on the news says the problem is
me i'm just a small town boy with big
american dreams
the world's going crazy and they lying
to us
don't know who the bullying show
[Music]
y'all missing what was written in them
pages that was history they wrote now
you want to change it
you racist
you hate this why you want us all to be
locked up in cages i can't stand the
left everything they say is depressing
ship them to the middle east they can
learn oppression believe me i mean this
quite literal i love liberty but i
liberals wear a mask stay home complain
and moan talk about privilege on your
phone in your range road starbucks mango
fufu whatever the cloth i'm cut from can
handle any weather you just paper in the
rain we ain't the same stand for the
flag only near when i pray
i just pray we go back to the old days
land of the free home of the brain i'll
pause that there so this is a popular
expression now
to say i stand for the flag and i kneel
only for god the left makes fun of this
phrase
it's a good phrase it's a good rule of
thumb
because you don't want to say i don't
know for any man no i you you kneel for
god you need to have genuine humility
that's the beginning of wisdom but you
stand for your country and and what the
left does is exactly the opposite right
they refuse to get on their knees and
pray to god and they
kneel for the flag not as a sort of
prayer but in disrespect starting with
colin kaepernick and all the rest of
them so
it you're seeing this inversion and it's
not just on politics it's not just covid
it's not just the economy it's not just
racism it's not just
ultimately it all goes back to this
religious question cardinal manning said
it very well at bottom all human
conflict is theological i i think that's
what tom is getting at here right it's
in god we trust you don't know who to
believe you don't know what's going on
the only thing we can do is pray even
our patriotism we've got to ground that
in prayer to make sense of it of who we
are of what our country is now let me
ask you something what if there were
someone out there who kept a log of
every single thing that you did every
minute of the day
that would be pretty creepy right well
what if i told you that's exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider let's say it's att
let's say it's comcast
they're allowed to store logs of every
website you've ever visited they can
legally sell this data to anyone
that's why i use expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your
internet provider cannot see or log what
you do online
a ton of vpns claim to have a no logs
policy but they've been caught logging
customer activity expressvpn is the only
vpn i trust because they use trusted
server technology so simple you download
it for your phone for your computer for
your tablet one button you click it's on
your data are encrypted anonymized stop
letting people keep logs of what you do
online go to expressvpn.com
michael yt
right now find out how you can get three
months
for free tom keep going
me i'm just a small town boy with big
american dreams
the world's going crazy and they lying
to us
don't know who to
[Music]
i see through all the illusions refuse
to human rumors are accepted we are
losing easy to get caught up consumed by
the consumer truth is so diluted people
starve off their confusion comfort is
the killer your dreams execution cool
persecution if i make a contribution
home of the brave look like a mental
institution and it will be revolution if
we can't find resolution and a threat is
a promise stand up pay homage they tell
lies i'm being honest that's the time is
upon us i know that god got us so i'm
fighting in his honor hear the cries of
the crusaders as we're strapping up our
armor he said set a higher ground to
drown and they drama if i die for what i
love just gotta take a quick pause i
don't have a ton of commentary here but
uh cries of the crusaders is it awesome
awesome pretty awesome dave's fault
great stuff keep going we fighting for
our freedom don't believe what they've
been feeding be the change you want to
see the warriors that we're
says needing problem is me i'm just a
small town boy with big american dreams
the world's going crazy and they lying
to us
[Music]
we don't trust the news the government
or pharma we just want freedom that you
have that to offer we don't want the
lies the politics or the drama we just
want the life that was promised by our
fathers we don't trust the news the
government or pharma we just want
freedom that you have that to offer we
don't want the lies the politics or the
drama we just want the life that was
promised by pause it right there so
he's saying we don't trust the news
we don't trust the government we don't
trust pharma right big pharma so like
the medical public health industry we
don't trust that either and so it raises
this legitimate question well then what
does it mean to be a patriot it sounds
like you hate the country we love
america it's this weird thing where the
conservatives are the most patriotic
people in the country but we're the most
irritated by everything that is going on
in the country right now in part because
we love the country and we want to make
america great again trump got accused of
this he said well if you want to make
america great again you're saying
america is no good right now which means
you're not patriotic no that's not it
we're saying that america could be so
much better and we love our country and
we love our countrymen and we want we
want it to
live up to a real flourishing
well-ordered political society how are
you gonna do that you're not gonna do
that with this squishy relativism of
america is just whatever we wanted you
know america is just whatever america is
at any given moment man you know and
it's not if there's no basis in in
reality or truth or the law or justice
it's just sort of whatever the majority
of people want at any given moment
that's what america is and should be and
what conservatives say is no that's not
true america right now just to use one
example this is not in the music video
obviously but
to say we're killing a million babies a
year through abortion that's really bad
that's that's a huge indictment of our
country
it's not a good country that kills
almost a million babies a year
now
we're not supposed to be killing these
babies it's not in the constitution it's
not there's no
right natural right or civil right to
kill these babies you got to get rid of
it and you've got to ground your country
and your system of law in
some truth in something that's firm and
something beyond just the whims and
preferences of people which are going to
change all the time and that is the
point that tom is making here it's
in god we trust
that there there is a law
there is a transcendent moral order
there is objective reality okay that
we've got and we're not living up to
that right now and we're denying that
and we're perverting that right now but
so we've we've got all the more so we've
got to throw ourselves down in prayer
we've got to
clear the crazy fogginess of modernity
from our minds see
moral reality for what it really is and
live up to that keep going
says
[Music]
the world's
[Music]
don't know who to believe don't know who
to believe certain god we trust i don't
know if i can believe
i can't believe the government i can't
believe the media i can't believe the dr
faucis i can't believe the bureaucrats i
can't believe many of my fellow
americans so what do you do in god we
trust get back to that fundament that
basic unmoving objective truth that's
the only way that you're going to get
liberty again right he says i love
liberty but i i often hate liberals you
know right because they're they're not
getting it they've perverted something
they're misrepresenting something we
want to get back down to that which is
really real that which is not moving and
ultimately that's going to lead you to
god
much
more coherent
than the slam poetry from the actress
lady about the ukraine war instead of
mother russia call me much more coherent
than the beat poetry from kamala harris
another good job from tom mcdonald
[Music]
[Music]
you